un reporter de la télévision d'État
iranienne montre que le calme est revenu
dans la prison des vignes
même les détenus dorment paisiblement
un important incendie s'est déclaré
quelques heures plus tôt il y a eu des
affrontements aussi au moins quatre
détenus sont morts une soixantaine ont
été blessées la République islamique
d'Iran soutient qu'il y a eu une émeute
entre les murs
l'événement coïncide avec une autre
journée de protestation pour dénoncer la
mort de la jeune iranienne Macha Amini
il y a un mois des centaines de
personnes arrêtées dans les
manifestations aurait été envoyé dans
cette prison
l'endroit est tristement célèbre car
plusieurs dissidents politiques qui sont
détenus
Zara Kazami a été battu en Iran il y a
presque 20 ans la photo journaliste
Tyrano canadienne Zahra kazimi est morte
des suites de mauvais traitements à la
prison des villes alors qu'elle
photographiait des familles de
prisonniers à montréalaise de 55 ans a
été battu agressé sexuellement et
torturé
le président iranien Ibrahim raïti
accusé Joe Biden d'avoir provoqué le
chaos dans son pays
président des États-Unis a réitéré son
appui aux femmes de Téhéran dans la rue
pour plus de liberté
les États-Unis ainsi que plusieurs ONG
s'inquiètent de la situation dans la
prison des villes des prisonniers
étrangers sont encore détenus
Montréal